le parti démocrate dans la tourmente
première étape de la primaire visant à
établir le candidat démocrate à
l'investiture pour la présidentielle de
novembre prochain
le caucus de l'iowa a tourné au fiasco
déjà retardé de trois jours les
résultats définitifs n'ont pas permis à
la direction du parti de proclamer un
vainqueur
la raison un bug informatique de
l'application mobile du parti démocrate
un imbroglio auxquels il faut rajouter
la volonté du chef du parti démocrate
tom perez de réexaminer les résultats
trop c'est trop à la lumière des
problèmes qui sont apparus dans
l'application du processus de sélection
des délégués et afin que les gens aient
confiance dans les résultats
j'appelle le parti démocrate de l'iowa a
commencé immédiatement un réexamen une
réévaluation peu probable dans la course
à l'investiture va s'accélérer dans les
prochains jours annoncé vainqueur
surprise du scrutin avec 20 6,2 pour
cent des suffrages
pitbull dj gee a salué sa victoire ça a
été une semaine extraordinaire et nous
sommes complètement électrisée par
l'énergie avec laquelle nous venons ici
et par l'extraordinaire validation que
nous avons eues dans l'iowa lundi de la
vision portée par cette campagne je suis
aussi conscient et humble devant le fait
que le new hampshire et le new hampshire
et que lemieux enchères n'est pas le
genre d'endroit qui va laisser l'iowa ou
qui que ce soit d'autre
8 dire quoi faire une victoire également
revendiqué par bernie sanders qui
arriverait selon les résultats publiés
en deuxième position avec 26,1 % des
voix le sénateur du vermont a dénoncé
les conditions du vote lors de ce caucus
cette bourde est extrêmement injuste
pour les habitants de l'iowa
elle est injuste pour les candidats tous
les candidats et tous leurs supporters
maintenant comme chacun le sait le
processus dans l'iowa est extrêmement
compliqué selon moi beaucoup trop
compliqué fort je pense que ce qu'il
s'est passé avec le parti démocrate de
l'iowa est un scandale
j'ai été aussi mal préparés qu'ils aient
utilisé un processus si compliqué basées
sur des technologies de tester des
scores bien loin de celui du favori de
la campagne joe biden qui n'arrive qu'en
quatrième position avec 15,8 pour cent
des voix il se positionne derrière la
sénatrice elizabeth warren et ses 18 %
une ouverture de campagne chaotique que
les onze candidats encore en lice
voudront rapidement oublier la prochaine
étape de la primaire aura lieu dans le
new hampshire le 11 février prochain
[Musique]